Вітаю! Мене звати Михайло Малий.
Уже два роки я мешкаю у Німеччині і щодня відкриваю для себе цю країну.
Так сталося, що саме тут я став затятим велосипедистом.
Щодня, незважаючи на погоду і пору року
я їжджу на роботу на велосипеді, долаючи мінімум по 20 кілометрів на день.
Однак для більшості німців це не є чимось особливим.
Сотні тисяч людей тут не уявляють собі ані дозвілля,
ані повсякдення без велосипеда.
Тож сьогодні я пропоную вам вирушити разом зі мною
у німецький велотур вихідного дня.
Поїхали!
Я виїжджаю від будівлі редакції Дойче Веллє у Бонні
і вирушаю до краю виноробів – Арської долини.
Моя ціль – виноробне селище Вальпорцгайм,
що за майже 40 кіломерів від Дойче Веллє.
Дорогою я покажу вам, як облаштоване веложиття в Німеччині
з усіма його перевагами і -  куди ж без них? – недоліками.
Початок маршруту пролягає мальовничою велодоріжкою вздовж Рейну.
Тут можна побачити ось такі
дивовижні триколісні лежачі веломобілі
з "пілотом"  у повній екіпіровці
і дівчат у літніх сукнях на сіті-байках.
З велодоріжки відкривається вид на гору Драхенфельс
що означає "скеля дракона".
Саме на ній герой саги про Нібелунгів
Зіґфрід нібито вбив дракона.
Однак заглядаючись на краєвиди, треба пильнувати.
Адже далеко не на всіх велодоріжках у Німеччині
є розділювальна смуга,
що відмежовує зустрічний рух.
Саме тому краще триматися якомога правіше.
Якщо ви думаєте, що в Німеччині все продумано, то помиляєтеся.
На велодоріжках трапляються
небезпечні місця
ось такі, як тут.
Висота - метрів п'ять.
Просто закінчується велодоріжка.
Немає ані паркану, ані сітки,
тобто під час зіткнення можна запросто злетіти вниз.
Подолавши половину маршруту, я заїжджаю у місто Ремаген.
Це дуже захопливо,
коли на запланованому веломаршруті
трапляються такі визначні історичні місця.
У Ремагені у березні 1945 року були запеклі бої
між американськими військами і Вермахтом
за стратегічний міст, що вів на правий берег Рейну.
Про тижневу артилерійську і танкову битву
зняли масштабний фільм "Ремагенський міст".
Тепер у вцілілих опорах мосту розташований "Музей миру".
А на верхівці майорять прапори Німеччини і США.
Зараз я зупиняюсь і штовхаю велосипед.
У Ремагені, як і у більшості німецьких міст,
велика пішохідна зона.
Про це свідчить ось такий знак
Фусгенгерцоне.
Проїзд велосипедистом у пішохідній зоні
найбільш поширене порушення
з боку велосипедистів у Німеччині.
Якщо ви це тут зробите – штраф сягатиме 30 євро.
Якщо проїхати по пішохідній зоні на великій швидкості
додайте ще 15 євро.
Для тих, хто не помітив знак, прямо на асфальті написано:
велосипедист, будь ласка, злізь з велосипеда!
Та ще й відповідний малюнок.
Однак мені не довелося довго чекати, щоб помітити порушників.
Буквально за 5 хвилин це правило порушили
близько десяти велосипедистів
Якби поліція тут влаштувала засідку,
можна було б за день зібрати кілька тисяч євро штрафів.
Час звертати з велодоріжок біля Рейну і вирушати
у напрямку Арталь, тобто долини річки Ар.
А для тих, хто вперто не бажає злазити з велосипеда,
ставлять ось такі перепони.
Хочеш-не-хочеш, а злазити треба.
Уздовж річки Ар, притоки Рейну,
велодоріжки стають вужчими і рух тут повільніший.
Часом навіть бувають велосипедні затори.
Також вражає велика кількість малечі на велосипедах,
яка разом з батьками вирушила у тур вихідного дня.
Таке враження, що у Німеччині діти вчаться ходити
і їздити на велосипеді одночасно.
Загалом у Німеччині 72 мільйони велосипедів
на 80 мільйонів жителів.
Давайте зупинимо кількох велосипедистів і запитаємо,
чому вони обрали такий спосіб проведення вікенду
і що возять із собою.
Мені подобається бути на свіжому повітрі,
особливо коли гарна  погода,
дуже приємно їхати чудовими ландшафтами.
Он там мої друзі.
Ми зробили маленький тур сьогодні вздовж річки Ар
і просто насолоджувалися цим днем.
Звісно, з собою у мене вода.
Також треба мати банан або яблуко,
щоб перекусити,
і сонцезахисні окуляри з надією на гарну погоду.
Бути наодинці із собою.
Забути про весь світ
ось що значить для мене їзда на велосипеді.
Раніше я їздив тридцять кілометрів щодня,
коли працював учителем у школі.
Зараз щоранку, коли вигулюю собаку,
проїжджаю чотири кілометри.
З собою головне мати гаманець
і ось такий ремонтний комплект для шин.
Цей клей за 5 хвилин заклеює прокол.
Далі на маршруті з’являються мальовничі виноградники.
Такі казкові краєвиди піднімають настрій.
Здається, що виноградники сягають неба.
Коли дивишся на цей середньовічний замок
у променях сонця в оточенні зелених гір,
це аж ніяк не асоціюється з ядерною війною.
Однак цей краєвид відкривається саме з оглядового майданчика
на вході в підземний бункер на випадок ядерного удару.
Ще одне історичне місце на велошляху в Арській долині.
Неподалік міста Арвайлер
розташований бункер часів "холодної війни".
Саме тут планували розмістити
керівництво ФРН у разі ядерної загрози.
Бункер розрахований на три тисячі людей
і має 17 кілометрів тунелів.
Ось там – вхід до підземелля.
Якщо вам цікаво подивитися, що всередині,
напишіть у коментарях, і ми побуваємо тут наступного разу.
Найлегший відрізок - спуск з гір у долину.
Це останні півтора кілометра мого маршруту
і я в'їжджаю до запланованого пункту призначення
селища Вальпорцгайм.
Долина Арталь – найбільший регіон Німеччини
де вирощують червоний виноград.
Уже вечоріє.
У маленькому селищі я шукаю винарню
і заїжджаю у перший ліпший заклад.
Моєму здивуванню немає меж
посеред села стоїть винарня з Мішленівською зіркою.
Рік заснування 1246-ий!
Запитаємо, чим тут частують велосипедистів.
Ми рекомендуємо скуштувати Бургундер раннього та пізнього збору.
Ці вина зроблені з особливого сорту винограду,
який росте лише тут, біля Ару.
Це легке вино.
І цей смачний напій саме те, що треба для велосипедиста.
В долині річки Ар відчувається неабияка спокуса випити вина.
Воно тут у кожній винарні своє,
має неповторний смак і виробляється в обмеженій кількості.
Однак якщо ви за кермом велосипеда,
ви можете випити в Німеччині лише один келих.
Так само, як і водій авто.
На весь маршрут я витратив чотири години.
Попереду ще шлях назад.
Нічого не розбив – смартфон цілий,
і сили ще є, бо робив зупинки на відпочинок.
Чекаємо на ваші коментарі і пропозиції щодо того,
що ще вас цікавить у Німеччині!
До зустрічі!